my dad died five years ago and we try to
get my mom to move up and live with us
here in New York and she just refused
you want to live the keys in the house
where she and my dad spent many years
together after the third time she fell
and they didn't find her for a couple of
hours I said mom we have to do something
we can't just let this keep happening so
I hired these women to live with her in
shifts which of course she hated so she
got a stranger sleeping on her couch and
they're stealing my garbage bags mom
they're not stealing a girlfriend at
tedmed I ran into an a gentleman named
Eric dishman who is part of an
organization with between it's a joint
venture between a general electric and
Intel and one of the things are working
on is called the magic carpet so it's a
carpet you install in the home of your
loved one doesn't take good or bad it
just says this is how Rick's mom walks
when things are okay and then all of a
sudden in a day where her balance is off
or gate is off or she hasn't touched the
carpet until you know ten o'clock in the
morning and I know my mom always has
coffee at eight thirty in the morning
the the system sends me a message so
there's no cameras no not invading no
invasion of privacy nobody sleepy
undercount Sandri stealing your garbage
bags but the product is not out it's
still in research phase and then I found
out about things like this this is the
jawbone the up band I know that Nike is
here and body media's here there's all
these devices now that Kevin and Gary
you're going to talk about later that do
kind of the same thing they create a
baseline so every night now my son asked
me dad did you walk through 10,000 feet
there are steps today it measures my
sleep at night the idea is that my
friend Dean Ornish told me that a lot of
doctors believe right now we're spending
eighteen percent of our gdp on
healthcare and if you look at the trend
line they're saying by 2025 is going to
be forty percent which is obviously
insane we all know we're paying more and
more every month through our insurance
the idea is that three years before one
of us is in an ambulance on the way to
the hospital our body has been giving
off all kinds of signals and signs and
data but we've not been paying attention
to it so one of the ideas is that if we
were wearing devices like this which are
actually kind of fun my brother and I
compared our sleep at night but kids
asked me if I met my goal the game
vacation of health instead of dealing
with it when you're already sick but
doing it in the early stages makes this
a month maybe this is a way of sort of
addressing the healthcare situation